large numbers of immigrants have been
waiting for days for the authorities
here in Berlin to process their
applications for asylum some have even
been camping out here
many of them have fled the fighting in
Syria they say they had no choice but to
leave their homes were destroyed and
life as they knew it no longer exists it
is damaged completely it is damaged
completely by water no house is no
possibility to live um okay
I'd like to be able to study here in
Germany I want to take an active part in
society in Syria many of our rights were
taken away a la tierra gardener now
modern indian cinnamon her hoof nanny
and not a hobby
I've come here because Germany is a safe
place and the rule of law is still in
force I want my children to experience
freedom and security I want them to
study and I want to work education is
the most important thing the federal
government says an estimated 800,000
asylum seekers are expected to arrive in
Germany this year during the first half
of this year most refugees came from
Serbia Kosovo Albania and Macedonia most
of them are economic refugees the next
largest group of applicants came from
Syria there are also refugees from Iraq
and Afghanistan among the other
countries are some from African nations
several startup companies have been
organized to help the refugees find jobs
for example Maya hable plans to open a
four star hotel called utopia so far
it's just an idea but her goal is to
employ asylum seekers as Hotel staffers
ones this can be staged this it's very
important for us to be taken seriously
this is not just another social program
that's that's what's here the hotel
project is going to happen no Marlin
utterly nor
but sexy hotel in central Berlin nama
but it's also going to be different
because we'll employ these very special
people one does the atmosphere and it'll
be different because of the
multicultural atmosphere
I just wish disconsolate LD clean it hey
Bo and her colleagues are still looking
for a place to build the hotel and
they'll need money from investors about
eight to ten million euros Vistage isn't
a Matsuzaka does it's important to
stress that these people are not victims
they have a lot of different skills
talents and qualifications what's them
give this nut to at the same time we
will face specific challenges when we
hire them for example there's the
language barrier that's a gun onto an
Amish package about a year that you
visibly just put it up for Elijah yeah
but on top of that some of them may need
psychological or social support van can
you list the shabbat without others may
need legal advice as they go through the
process of applying for asylum yet often
tides today I often tide status vitae
cake Latvian mores another project gives
asylum seekers the opportunity to try
out different occupations to see which
one suits them best many of the skilled
trade professions say they don't have
enough trainees right now thousands of
training positions are still open the
German Chamber of Commerce and Industry
calls for a program in which asylum
seekers could start job training while
their applications are being processed
and where they would not be deported
while they're in the program or for two
years after they finish it
Azula my Asylum has traditionally been
aimed at providing temporary protection
from persecution but the persecution
that we've seen in Syria or northern
Iraq could continue for the next 10 or
15 years so we have to take a new look
at our Cylon laws we have to come up
with ways to help these people become
part of our society we have to offer
them a new homeland it was like as a
chef Sylvain Hanoi I'm Otsu beaten many
of the refugees who have come to Germany
have lost everything they want to build
a new life here and to do that they need
help
you